[Music]
so my name is may talents in I'm gonna
tell you what I'm doing for a living
today I'm going to present you with a
project that I did like a while ago when
I actually tried to learn learn Python
so um in my profession I used to use R
for all my analysis and then I realized
that I need to move to Python because
all the rest of the world is in Python
so I went to she codes and to study
Python to learn Python and then
eventually I needed to ended up with the
final project and I wanted to have a
project that is relevant for my everyday
life and will ease my work because
whenever you do something repetitively
you want just to automate it so I
decided to do something that will help
me so I ended up with a synopsis and I'm
so I'm gonna show you what synopsis is
so I am I confess I'm a pity me ologist
someone is is there a person in here
that know what the epidemiologist is wow
this is so many people usually there's
only one so for those of you doesn't
know usually people are saying that
thinking that epidemiologist is someone
that is especially taun especially on
skin disease no don't show me your moles
and the other people who don't know what
a premie ologist is think that it's all
about epidemic but it's it's true some
of it is related to epidemic but it's
all not about the outbreaks like the
measles outbreak I know nothing about it
so don't ask me about it
just vaccinate your kids so
epidemiologist is actually a person who
deals with them it's the logical aspect
of medical research so for a living what
I do
I designed the studies
I think about the best analytic solution
to answer the static question and a lot
of the methods that America was
mentioned before like he was it was a
mentioned the for us returning repeated
measurements we do it with bonferroni it
changed the p-value remember so we use
bonferroni we use FDR we use all this
stuff just to I guess to get into the
same solution and he showed you the diff
and if this is a something that we use
for causal inference so we do this a lot
so there is a so I'm the the data
scientist of medical research because we
use the same exactly the same method
very similar method at least so my
specialties as epidemiologist is dealing
with observational studies of electronic
medical records I'm not sure if you know
I'm sure you do
I'm not sure but I'm sure that every
encounter that you have with the health
system in here in Israel for the last 25
years
is recorded in the computer so if you
call to them okay it is recorded if you
do a blood test it is recorded the
results are recorded if you have a
prescription it's recorded and if you go
to the pharmacy and buy purchased the
medication it's all recorded and it's
all gathered into one big database for
specifically me I'm working at the
college Research Institute and we're
gathering all this data and eventually
we take all this data and we ask some
question on a data and answer with what
we have at the data so in the lifecycle
of a study that I do first step is to
gather all the information from
everywhere from the all the fields at
the right date there this the right code
and then to have a big flat file and
once we have a big flat file I really
want to feel that that I want to play
with the data I want to make sure that I
have a complete data I want to see if
there my data is missing it's not messy
is it like is there outliers is it
complete I want to see the data and this
is why I see all about it seeing the
data
it's a visualized snapshot of variables
in a database so the synopsis is the
first exploration of the variables in
the database and its central is the main
important features of the features we
call it variables but it's the features
of the features and it do it in a
structure visualized approach the how so
I needed to die did this project to
study Python so I wrote it in Python and
I use the regular libraries that pandas
an impediment leave and all you need to
run synopsis is Titan and data set so I
can talk a lot about about synopsis but
I think that a live demo would be better
to show you what's in ops it is you know
how always they told you that in
demonstrations you don't suppose to have
a live demo but I'm so sure this some
presented the live demo so all you need
is to invert it right import synopsis
and then synopsis process CSV and then
it's open a file and then you have to
choose your database in this case I
choose my database as a CSV file I've
prepared ahead of time
I've prepared a fiction Airy database
that is based on on distributions real
distributions that's we have in in the
Mahon from declared database these are
not the real data because we're not
allowed to show nothing from it but it's
all based on the real distribution that
we have so generally you have this is so
seriously this is the the synopsis of
you have 15 variables in this that
you have 50,000 observations and this is
a synopsis of the database this is the
visual way of the database so in here
you see all the variables in the data
and what type of variable the graphic
representation the basic statistic
missing and outliers so the thing is
that when I explore every data file I do
this repeatedly for every single
variable to fill the data so synopsis
put it all in the same table so let's go
over it and understand what we have in
here so the indexed date you see it's me
it means nothing just mean it means a
date for where you start to follow up a
person and then what is important for me
is to see that there is no missing data
at the index date because I need every
but everyone to have a starting point so
the index that is less relevant in here
but what you can see you see the first
line is static and then you can move
forward so the next the next variable
that I have in the database is source of
data source of data it's a single
variable meaning that there is no no
variance in this variable every single
observation of the data set has the same
value for this this variable so it
doesn't help me I can just delete this
variable I need I have nothing to do
with this variable but this this thing I
get in a snapshot with with synopsis
okay var one weeks it's a variable that
is count counting in weeks
okay so it's I say that is a continuous
variable and and I see the distribution
it's a histogram but if I'm below if I'm
one of them on the basic statistic I can
see that it start from minus one which
doesn't make sense okay so there is a
problem with my data
I saw it in a snapshot and I'm now I
need to go back to my data understand
what is this minus one because it
shouldn't be - they're supposed to be
only positive values in here but
something is missing in here is it's
normally distributed with disability
with long tail long left tail so I need
to think what do I do with these
outliers you see there is 388 outliers I
made the outlier based on the three IQR
from the dead three interquartile range
from the median a distance and so and
another thing is that the debt this
variable is available for only fifty
percent of the population so now I need
to think what do I do with this it gives
me the opportunity to think ahead of
time like before I even modeled
something what do I have in here I would
like how they approach this variable and
it gives me the opportunity to think
ahead of time do I want to do multiple
imputation in 50 percent not recommended
for our died at least I need to think
what to do in here another another
variable I can see that it's not
distributed normally it has a long right
tail now in what I want to know if my
data is correct about this variable
because I know from past experience that
for example BMI LDL they're all
distributed the same as this
distribution is they're not normally
distributed does this fit to add it to
my prior knowledge so in here I can know
if my variable is okay this is a classic
[Music]
present representation of a digit
preference they know what a digit
preference is okay so you seen here it's
kind of normally distributed right but
look not all the values have have the
same chances of representation for
example do you remember that back at the
old days when the nernst measure your
blood pressure is she used to do it with
the pump with a manual pump and then if
it was 100
in three she did wrote right 103 because
she couldn't be that specific right so
she wrote 105 or 110 103 did not get get
the same representation is 105 and 101
in 100 so this is a digit preference and
in here you you in a snapshot you can
see that there is a digit preference and
you need to decide what to do with this
do you categorize it you change it to
different variable yeah it could but I
try to to have a various small bins
specifically in here what do you have
like 250 and then 275 and you have you
in between yeah
and I think that the beans are
calculated based on the distribution of
the remember but it's a good question
in here you see a rate of an event which
is 72% and here you see another variable
that is not normally distributed I would
do if this would be an outcome I might
run it for Sonic regression or I would
just dichotomize it to different
different categories in here again this
is for example in here this is something
between 0 0 to 12 1 to 12 actually maybe
this is month so maybe you can see
seasonality in here maybe not
another categorical variable and aren't
continuous well this is perfectly
normally distributed nice to have gender
you would think that gender would be
only male and female right this is what
you expect from your database but when
you have a big database you have
everything and for example in here fine
I suddenly found like a you meaning
undefined gender right so in a snapshot
I could tell wait I cannot say when
women is one men are 0 I have to to deal
with this you so this is something
and then I need to go back to the
database and decide what to do
probable one very 11 very rare event
variable 12 well it's kind of distribute
between 0 and 29 but most of the events
are at 0 like most of the values are at
0 and this is very weird distribution
that you want to know ahead of time
before you enter it something like this
to the model that something's very weird
is happening here also it's 96% missing
so it's only available for 3% of the
population so I would think if to
consider this variable and the last one
you can see that in here there are
actually two distribution not only one
so if you would think like if you would
have a median and I mean you would see
you would think okay this is normally
distributed data but you can see that
there is another bump there at the left
so then you maybe I would choose to just
treat it as two different distribution
so this is synopsis and let's go back to
the presentation
okay so basically I wanted to nups to
use upon the data frame and then I
realized that it in my own
we barely used upon the data frame we
mainly use we extract our data in the
SQL and then we analyzed in our most of
the time and and only different kind of
analysis we do in in Python so I wanted
synopsis to be first useful for me to is
my work into my friends and second what
I wanted it to be very generic so
everybody could use it so I this is why
I added the CSV feature but it wasn't
that easy because once you take one once
you have your SQL data and transform it
to a CSV it's encoded in a different way
than it does when you transfer from R to
CSV so I needed I I did a kind of a
trick I'll show you later in the code
what I did to make sure that synopsis
can read all the types of CSV and once
you have your files used in abscess it
generates graphs and it stored it in a
very specific directory that it creates
because the output is an HTML file so I
needed to generate this graphs and it
all doesn't automatically so this it's a
nice it's a nice program to have and we
use it a lot of them home because every
flat file that we have the first thing
to do is run synopsis and it's so
helpful and it just cuts a lot of
mistakes that we can do later on so
eventually I would like so now this to
have a web application where the the
prison he is it doesn't need to know
nothing about I don't know they just put
their database and then they get the
results and I do it one time it's very
important to communicate the the the
result of the synopsis to to your
kelabra
like I mean I'm working a lot with
external clinicians so I always thought
I didn't for now I just take the HTML
and I print it to PDF and then I send it
to them and then we discuss I wanted to
do it jet synopsis to generate PDF
automatically it was so hard to generate
video from HTML it needed so many
dependencies that it was too much for me
so I said ok I'll file I'll have
somebody to write better program to
generate videos and then I'll use it
that in for now I'm I'm still waiting
I'll be happy to hear if you have any
suggestions and tackling large database
for now I use synopsis and up to 100
million people observation with two
thousand variables but its own computer
computing power so what I was thinking
maybe if we have a bigger larger
database maybe I can just sample because
if you have distribution of 1 million
would be the same distribution once
100,000 so maybe I should just sample
and then run synopsis 1 when we have a
big database but this is something for
the future of course and I wanted to
show you some everything is on the
github stand and with all the
explanation this is well this is the
code right so there is if you want if
you go on my github you can see all the
explanation how to use it the dependency
is everything in here and for the code
because I know that you guys like to see
some code 3 wait
okay so first I use the process CSV or
process pandas the data frame because
you can automatic from pandas and then
and then this is this the trick I did I
just I just tried it try to use utf-8 I
don't know why there was a difference
between the tf8
the small media faith and the logic it
wasn't it's not supposed to be but I
kind of because it's tested so many
times but there was difference I know
why three points the latest one so
anyway and if you have a different
encoding you can just add it to the list
and it will do it it will it will make
the encoding so and and many of my
friends were saying let me know this is
not working for me and I said though
what what was the message that you get
use a CSV file what did you use it excel
file
no so so I added this line that saying
use the CSV are not in Excel and
specifically if they don't know the
encoding just using utf-8 do whatever
you need to do to have it working and
then and then it's this is opening the
directory and then this is all I did a
class like all the logic are in here and
then eventually what was cool about this
project is is that they also had wakened
going too fast so I also had a back-end
and a front-end and I was able to have
the HTML so this is where the backends
go through my code I used the bootstrap
and I I just realized that my brother
and knows the backend at the front end
so I was able to using when I was
testing us in front of people so it was
cool and that's it generally this is
synopsis
[Applause]
you